من داخل قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هنا
بالمنطقه الغربيه وتحديدا ميدان مدينه جده
نشاهد كما يظهر امامكم على الكاميرا وصول
الدفعه الثانيه من رعايا السعوديين وغير
السعوديين ونتحدث على اكثر من 11 جنسيه
وصلوا تباعا الى مدينه جده بمجموع كل يصل
الى مئه وثمانيه وخمسين الشخص نتحدث على
السعوديين وكذلك من دول اوروبيه وايضا
كذلك من دول خليجيه تحديدا من قطر
والامارات والكويت واذا تحدثت على الدول
العربيه نتحدث على مصر والسودان وتونس
وفلسطين وغيرها من الدول كما يظهر امامكم
الان وصول السفينه جلاله الملك الرياض هي
السفينه الثانيه بعد ان وصلت السفينه
الاولى وهي سفينه الجبيل على على متنها
نتحدث على المتن المره الاولى 50 شخص على
هذه السفينه خمسه واربعين شخص والسفينه
الثالثه هي وصلت قبل قليل كذلك الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده نتحدث انه تبقى
واحده وكذلك السفير الخامسه هي سفينه خاصه
بالتمويل كافه الخدمات يتم تقديمها هنا من
قبل القطاعات الامنيه العامله هنا في
القاعده كذلك يتم انهاء كافه الاجراءات
السفر المتعلقه بالمسافرين والرعايه ومن
ثم ومن ثم سوف يتم عمليه تسكينهم في فنادق
جده والتاكد من صحتهم وتقديم كافه الرعايه
الطبيه لهم والخدمات اللوجستيه التي
يحتاجها هؤلاء المسافرين تحدثنا قبل قليل
مع مجموعه من الاوروبيين التي الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان وصولا من الخرطوم
وصولا الى بورت سودان ومن ثم وصولا الى
مدينه جده في رحله تتجاوز 14 ساعه كافه
الخدمات تقدم لهم يتم استقبالهم بالورد
والحلوى يتم التاكد من حالتهم الصحيه ومن
ثم تقديم الخدمات لهم وانهاء كافه اجراءات
السفر من ثم عمليه
لاستكمال عمليه اجراءتهم وصولا الى
بلدالهم نؤكد انه كافه اللاجئين هم بخير
وبصحه وبعافيه كبيره بعد التاكل من صح
نتحدث انه الان او تحديدا كما يظهر امامكم
الان وصلت السفينه الثالثه تبقى سفينه
واحده في طريقها سوف تصل بعد 45 دقيقه ومن
ثم السفينه الاخرى هي السفينه ينبع وهي
الخاصه
بالتمويل لهذه السفن الاربعه التي الخاصه
بعمليات الاجلاء سلطان هل هنالك اي عمليات
اجلاء اخرى مقرره غير السفن الخمس التي
تحدثت عنها يعني في دول اخرى طلبت من
المملكه او قدمت طلبات الى المملكه من اجل
المساعده في اجلاء رعاياها وفق معلوماتك
بالفعل كل الدول الشقيقه والدول الصديقه
والدول الاوروبيه التي طلبت من السعوديه
عمليه اجلائها الى مدينه جده تحديدا تم
قبولها وتم اجلاء كافه الرعايه السعوديه
في السودان وكذلك كافه الدول التي طلبت من
الحكومه السعوديه عمليات الاجلاء وصلوا
الى الى مدينه جده وتحديدا في قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه طبقه سفينه واحده اكدوا لنا
كافه الرعايه الموجودين انهم وصلوا باعداد
كامله بالرعايه وبالمواطنينهم وكذلك حتى
ايضا العاملين هل اتصلنا لك
الحديث مع اي من الرعايه الذين تم اجلائهم
لمعرفه طبيعه الاوضاع في السودان ام لا
حتى الساعه لم يتسنى لك سلطان
بالفعل التقيت بعدد كبير من الرعايه
وتحديدا من الجنسيه البلغاريه وكذلك
الجنسيه الكنديه وايضا سعوديات وكذلك شخص
اخر كويتي اكدوا سلامتهم واكدوا بصعوبه
الاوضاع وخطرها في السودان واكدوا وقدموا
جزيل شكرهم للحكومه السعوديه على تقديمهم
واجلائهم الى السعوديه ايضا هذا هو الكرو
او الطاقم الخاص بالخطوط السعوديه الخاص
بالطائره التي تعرضت لاحادث خلال الايام
الماضيه في مطار الخرطوم نشاهد الوصول
الطاقم وهو بكامل عددهم نتحدث عن الكابتن
وكذلك كافه
صحه وبسلامه كما يظهر امامكم الان تم
استقبالهم واجلائهم كامله
وبعد الحادثه التي تعرضت لها طائرتهم
التابعه لخطوط السعوديه في مطار الخرطوم
سلطان طيب
الرعايه الاجانب الذين يعني ساعدت المملكه
في اجلائهم ووصلوا الى جده من جده الى اين
سيتوجهون هل يعني سيعودون الى بلدانهم ام
لا سيمكثون لفتره في في المملكه ومن ثم
يعني تقرر البعثات الدبلوماسيه لهؤلاء
الرعايه يعني اما نقلهم الى بلدانهم يعني
اي معلومات عن الخطوه المقبله بالنسبه الى
هؤلاء
نعم نعم بدايه يتم استقبالهم هنا في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه ومن ثم ايصالهم الى من
ميناء جده لانهاء اجراءات السفر ونتحدث عن
الجوازات والجمارك وغيرها من القطاعات
الامنيه ومن ثم تسك نقلهم الى فنادق جده
سوف يقومون بالاستراحه هنالك لمده يوم او
يومين ومن ثم اتباعا انهاء اجراءاتهم
لنقلهم الى او تسفيرهم الى بلدانهم بعد
التاكد من صحتهم وتقديم كافه الخدمات
الخاصه بهم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات